hi my name is Weston Hutchins and I'm a
product manager for gke on Prem even
with more and more workloads moving to
the public cloud on-premise oft where
remains a necessity for many enterprise
organizations every Enterprise has apps
that are difficult to move to the cloud
or restrictions on where sensitive
workloads can run many are looking for a
true hybrid story one where they can
modernize the apps for the cloud but
continue running in their own data
center many companies have looked to
kubernetes to give them a consistent
environment between on-prem and cloud
but getting started with kubernetes is
challenging there are over 50
distributions and choosing the right
tools to install kubernetes can prove
daunting and then once you get a cluster
up and running you enter the land of day
to operations where you not only need to
lean but considerable operational
expertise to manage the lifecycle of a
kubernetes cluster we find a lot of
customers that start down the route of
building their own in-house DIY tooling
to manage kubernetes later struggled to
keep that tooling up to date Google's
answer for hybrid is cloud services
platform a stack that takes the best of
cloud native open technologies like
kubernetes and sto and lets you run them
in your data center but the key benefit
of CSP is the collection of cloud
services that integrate your on priming
cloud workloads into a single unified
experience services like binary
authorization for security unified
logging and monitoring through stack
driver or centralized policy management
that syncs access controls across all of
your clusters at next 19 will deep dive
into the infrastructure layer for CSP GK
on Prem GK and Ram takes all of the
technology behind gke
and installs it on top of vmware in your
data center once installed you register
your cluster with Google's cloud console
to give your administrators and
developers a single pane of glass for
managing their clusters and apps and I
talking next well take a detailed look
into a real-world use case Arctic one of
our CSP solution providers recently
rolled out G Khan Prem to one of their
customers Activa a telecommunications
services company
we'll walk throughout Tevas architecture
show how GK and Prem integrated with
their existing tools and workflows and
give some tips for your own installation
of GK on Prem check out the breakout
session online and we'll get you up and
running with GK on Prem in no time
[Music]